we are coming on the air right now with
breaking news because the u.s capitol
has been placed on lockdown what was
supposed to be a routine congressional
transaction on wednesday
turned into chaos in the nation's
capital
shocking photos and images coming from
inside federal buildings
where dozens of people have rushed past
police and security
to stage a takeover if you look up here
on to the inauguration stage
you can see there's a large number of
people we've watched them
climb up the scaffolding to get up there
celebrities are making their voices
heard with some
just a few short words issa rae tweeted
truly disgusted chris evans tweeted
i'm speechless and ashton kutcher
tweeted
support the peaceful transition of power
that's being a patriot
in the middle of today's scheduled
electoral count certification
initially overseen by vice president
mike pence
violence erupted outside of the capitol
building and soon developed into a
takeover of the congressional buildings
while the us capitol police is very
experienced d.c police of course
extremely experienced with big protests
they don't have
much experience dealing with something
like this where protesters have really
gotten inside
a government building there was an
evacuation for everyone inside via
underground tunnels including vice
president pence and members of congress
what happened
celebs on social media are pointing
directly to president trump
and his gathered supporters it would be
really great if we could be covered
fairly by the media the media is the
biggest problem we have as far as i'm
concerned
the trespassers seemingly spawned from a
president trump rally earlier that day
an event focused on protesting congress
certifying the electoral count from the
2020 presidential election
which president trump has continued to
discredit with baseless claims of voter
fraud we're going to walk down and i'll
be there with you
we're going to walk down we're going to
walk down
anyone you want but i think right here
we're going to walk down
to the capitol
and we're going to cheer on our brave
senators and congressmen and women
and we're probably not going to be
cheering so much for
some of them these statements are now
being credited for inciting the unlawful
takeover of these federal buildings
with many calling for the president's
impeachment jonathan van ness took to
instagram writing
trump still has two weeks left he must
be impeached
immediately several people are
highlighting last year's black lives
matter protests which were heavily
criticized by many in president trump's
administration
including the president himself cardi b
tweeted the irony is pretty funny
weren't people just wild animals in the
summer for demanding justice and now
chris evans followed up his earlier
message with just think of the carnage
had they
not been white dwyane wade tweeted black
people get pulled over and don't make it
out alive
we can't sleep in our own beds without
being killed we can't jog without being
killed
we can't walk down the street with our
hoodies up without being killed
but they can do this in reference to a
report that the national guard will not
be deployed
gabrielle union tweeted wonder why oh
yeah
right we know why the lack of support
from the national guard was another
major topic on social media
yvette nicole brown tweeted he incited
this riot and now won't allow the
national guard to quell it
realize what is happening in our nation
right now at this hour
our democracy is under unprecedented
assault
later in the day president-elect joe
biden specifically called out president
trump's lack of action
and called wednesday's events a
god-awful display
saying it's not a reflection of american
values
the scenes of chaos at the capitol do
not reflect a true america
do not represent who we are
what we're seeing are a small number of
extremists
president trump later tweeted this video
reaction
saying everyone who took part in the
day's events is quote
very special i know you're paying i know
you're hurt
we had an election that was stolen
from us it was a landslide election
and everyone knows it especially the
other side
but you have to go home now we have to
have peace